one thing i wondered when i was doing it
i was like how the [ __ ] do you get into
this
that's what i was gonna ask you as well
you know like like you said like skiing
and stuff like that even that is like i
think a lot of people think skiing is
kind of hard to get into a snowboarding
it's not
really you just go to a mountain you do
the weekend just try it out
and you get into it right it's not that
difficult but with a with drifting
uh it seems like there's a lot more
commitment and also it's just way harder
to get into like because when we try to
do the drifting video
they initially wanted us to buy a car
yeah we were like well what the [ __ ] are
we gonna do with the car after we're
done right
we just sell it back i'm like i don't
want to [ __ ] go through that that
sounds like a pain but yeah
you know even you can rent skis right
you can rent snowboards
how do you take that first leap to
getting into drifting
and also especially if you have no
background because those people at the
track
like the kids who've worked there i mean
they were like 17 teaching yeah
insane but you know they've obviously
grown up with it but how does someone
who came from like
investment banking you know get into
obviously he has so much money
which is which is one of the things
you'll probably need is money which is
the biggest thing i've found out i
didn't notice
like just even just one day of drifting
for us where
like some of us barely learned anything
i i feel um
still cost a lot of money yeah yeah so
how do you get into it like how do you
take that that original leap and how do
you know you want to do it i mean the
the pattern most people take
uh i mean when i started at least is you
start with your daily driver
you have some sort of car which can
drift and
you just try and make sure it doesn't
break too much
okay you know like you could this i mean
well let's be frank
most people start off on the street
right quiet street somewhere i mean
that's what most you know it's like a
parking lot or something like a parking
lot or anything
in the case of australia like an
industrial area or something like a
mountain road somewhere like a windy
road somewhere
where you just go you'll sit there for a
few minutes and okay there's no one
coming up behind me there's no traffic
okay let's go and you do a little lap or
something or
you know you have you go with friends
and spotters and things like that so
there's that
um the best way is to go to a circuit
uh the way what got me the when i
started to understand the feeling was
i had a an rx-7 back when i was like 18
i'd go to i'd go to the track and drive
around and
you know it was all very like oh yes you
know grip driving and
getting good times and breaking points
and clipping points and all this sort of
stuff i'm like
this is kind of this is kind of boring
it's just yeah i like doing the same
thing again and again yeah but then i'd
come in a bit too
hot and break too late in the back of
the car
sort of step out like oh yes
dude that was sick i'll do that again i
like try and like come out of the corner
and put a
you know you if you come out of a corner
you press the accelerator really hard
i think i mean look it's like video
games do the same thing mario kart
whatever it's like
you do something and the back of the car
slides out yeah yeah and
you yeah i do that but then you have the
flag masters like don't drift that
don't they get all annoyed at you so we
would
uh we started a little club in australia
in sydney
where i'm from and yeah sydney and we
have track days and we just go out there
and
you just do it like you just try like we
watch these japanese videos and
all these weird videos where they're
talking i can't understand what they're
saying but it's like
yeah okay we'll try that i can't
understand what they're saying but
they're pulling some sick drifts
basically yeah the best thing these days
is it's
so accessible now like these days you
can right there's
millions of videos and everything you
can just get into it super easy you're
one of them right
i feel like yeah i feel like no amount
of videos could prepare me
like i i actually tried to before the
day of the drift circuit i actually
tried to watch like a basic like how to
drift video
[ __ ] didn't help any by the way
because there's there's no
there's no like you you can read up
about it and learn about it all you want
but there's a different feeling where
you have to like
when you're just in this car seat in the
moment and you just have to like
you kind of have to feel your way
through yeah it's it's a it's a massive
seat of the pants thing
uh where you're you're trying to unlearn
what you already know like if you're not
if you're already a regular driver
it's you're doing everything is the
exact opposite of what you should be
doing you're not supposed to rev the
engine you're not supposed to dump the
clutch you're not supposed to spin the
wheels you're not supposed to slide
around you're not supposed to do any of
that stuff
yeah so it's the you know the yoda you
must unlearn what you have learned
and and that can be a bit of a hurdle uh
for some people
and for other people who maybe have a
bit more of a feel for it then it's a
bit
you get over that hump a bit faster but
honestly look anybody can do it it's not
it's not an unusual skill right to be
able to
drift i mean yeah i i managed to
somewhat pull it off at the end of the
day and yet you know i went into it not
knowing how to drive a manual at all
right so yeah it's not an unusual skill
but
uh i mean the the the gap is obviously
as you said like the commitment to keep
doing it is yes yeah yeah because you
have to buy i mean i actually have to
buy a car
dedicated to drift you can't just do
people use their like daily commuter
yeah yep they do
some well can they drift oh
okay you don't need you don't need a
crazy car to be able to drift you need
some like minor modifications but
generally any rear real drive car can
drift reasonably easy
yeah uh and the the downside is though
like if you have to go to work on a
monday morning and you've just you broke
something on
you know i i was going to say that too
like you know i've broken a gear box at
the track and i have to go to work on
the monday and it's like well i've only
got like first
second and fifth gear it's like okay
it's like
nick
just go around me i can't
that but you know these days um you know
people will have dedicated track cars
and again yeah that adds a whole extra
level of money too because i noticed
when we were at a busy there was so many
like foreigner friendly stuff and it was
like yeah
come come buy a car just come drift here
yeah every so the thing about ebisu is
abc is very special
ebisu is probably one of the if every
suit didn't exist that would be one less
reason for me to originally move here
right so it's been around for a long
time a long time episode was the track
that we were drifting out
yes yeah abc circuit up in fukushima uh
it
what makes it special is it's drift
friendly
it has not one track but many tracks
with different
sizes it's about seven yeah i mean
there's some there's some like open skid
pans and stuff like that
yeah uh they're all different kinds of
tracks
uh a lot of very famous drift videos uh
like you watch it famous troop video oh
that's where it was
right especially the you didn't you guys
didn't go to it there's a track called
minami
the south circuit which is infamous for
being
extremely difficult and extremely
rewarding to drive
it's extremely dangerous it's eaten i've
seen it break
legs and ribs from people crashing there
complete
people i saw a guy right off his car an
american guy
uh on his second lap he bought the car
there
second lap he went over the entry just
went straight into the wall banana the
front end
done yeah